so here you can see we've got a very
thin foil sample of dysprosium again
it's from the bottom end of the periodic
table very very reactive stored very
very carefully as a foil now if we open
very carefully we might see if the
method still there okay so a dysprosium
is used in nuclear fuel rods because
it's very good are capturing neutrons
which means you can modulate how hot a
nuclear reaction is getting which is why
it's used in power stations to prevent
the reactions from running away out of
control
so take off all of this foil and then we
can withdraw the sample so it's in this
really quite nice paper so is the sample
still there or beautiful here we see
this wonderful sample of dysprosium if
you mix dysprosium with cadmium and
sulfur it can be used in devices which
produce infrared beams now chemists use
infrared beams quite a lot because when
you a radiator a sample a compound with
infrared then certain absorbances will
occur which are specific to stretching
or bending modes which the molecule will
do and this is a way of therefore
scanning molecules and getting some
information about their composition and
structure beautiful foil you happen to
know anything about this element not a
thing that steve's domain yeah